>> How would you define happiness? >> Being at peace. >> The ability to , I
guess live a fulfilled life. >> It's more what you feel. What you can bring to
others and not so much what you see. >> They kind of bounce. Their eyes get all
happy. Their ears kind of go up. They get all loose, like their body language is
real loose. and yeah, their tails wag, like he's happy right now. >> How would
you measure it? >> Oh, I don't know, I, I don't measure nothin' really. I just
>> I'm happy.
>> I think I'd probably measure it by the number of times I smile every day. >>
I have no idea. I'd have to think about that for a sec. >> Their, their
attitude. Their, just the way they are personally. >> If I was a researcher and
I wanted to know how well you remembered something how could I do that? >> If
you're talking about like say, scientific experimentation. To have a control of
some sort, you could film the experience that a person has and then interview
that person. maybe have multiple people to interview, so you get different
points of view for the same event. And see how that differs. >> How would you
define memory? >>, >> It's an accumulation of information, data. far more
important is how you apply that, how you use it? >> The ability to retrieve
information from your past. >> I have to think about it. >> Things I bothered to
remember for >> Later use.
>> How would you define itchiness? >> Discomfort, yeah just general discomfort.
>> Something that's irritating you, and you have to scratch it. >> The intensity
of the itch would match the time length of scratching. >> With the amount that
they move around. >> You could ask a very forward question, like is there
something you need me to scratch? Right now.
>> Well that sounds a little personal. >> Very close friend, maybe you could do
that. >> So kind of like happin ess if you had to measure how itchy your dog was
right now, how would you do that? >> How would you quantify it? >> I'm going to
I'd, I'd definitely go with, like, how often they were scratching, or how often
they were doing sort of a full body shake. >> How would you measure stress? >> I
think you could measure stress by, obviously, there's, I'm sure medical ways
that you could measure stress. >> Yeah, the frown on my face, on my, on my mouth
I mean. >> Heartbeats probably.
The blood rushing to the head.